I was hosting my first dinner at
Stanford already and insecure hostess
this was a pretty stressful occasion for
me I had managed spaghetti and meatballs
which will call passable and I had
purchased and obscene quantity of cheap
trader joe's wine in an attempt to hide
my poor cooking we were well into our
third bottle when one of my new friends
Jennifer turned and said can I ask you a
question sure I said I hoped I wasn't
going to be anything about the cooking
because then I'd have to admit that
pretty much everything in front of us
had come out of a box instead she said
Anna you and Jason have been married for
two years what do you think is the
secret to love my heart was racing as
the room turned and stared at me first I
definitely do not believe that there's a
secret and secondly I also did not
believe that being married for two years
qualified me as any sort of relationship
expert I can't remember what I said but
I can guarantee that at that time it was
neither true nor helpful
it was one of those moments where I
really really wished I had an answer I
spent a lot of time thinking about this
question and thanks to a lot of you who
came to me to ask for love advice you
know who you are Jackie I'm here in
front of you one and a half years later
with what I think is a true and helpful
answer love is a wave with highs and
lows some of our deepest lows are
conflict and although our relationship
might appear perfect on the outside
Jason and I are no different for most
couples one of our deepest lows happened
five years ago my mom was diagnosed with
breast cancer I was devastated I called
Jason and he came home from work
immediately he bought me a train ticket
from New York to Boston and he walked me
to Penn Station at four in the morning
the next few months were challenging to
say the least I commuted from Boston to
New York trying to care for my mother
and also trying to do a good job in my
work as an investment banking analyst
one weekend my mom seemed to be doing
well so I decided that I was going to go
home and catch up on my work in New York
Jason was on vacation across the country
and he decided to surprise me by coming
back early of course I totally agreed to
go to a short dinner somewhere in the
neighborhood 30 minutes later we found
ourselves still stuck in a cab our cab
driver had committed the eighth cardinal
sin known only to New Yorkers he had
taken us through Times Square
45 minutes later we finally arrived at a
charming cubby hole in the west village
that charmingly kept its reservations on
pen and paper and charmingly had lost
our reservation an hour and a half later
we were finally seated two hours later
we had obtained bread and water with the
promise of wine on the way two and a
half hours later was when I completely
lost it I got mad at Jason I yelled at
him and I accused him of the most
heinous of offences trying to do
something nice for me how dare he
despite my egregious behavior we were
married in 2012 this is one of our
winning photos although I remembered
talking through this issue I still
wasn't sure why Jason forgave me so a
few weeks ago I called him to ask him
about this and he said at the time you
had an aura of gloom around you
seriously an aura of gloom yes an aura
of gloom I blame the context I didn't
blame you we had had so many happy
memories and I could see a path forward
to many more happy memories to come love
is a wave with highs and lows when I was
researching love i came across the work
of chip knee a psychologist who studies
how we behave in relationships
particularly during conflict as it turns
out we all have these mental models that
deeply impact how we behave even though
we don't realize the first is this
concept of destiny the idea of meant to
be we're all familiar with this concept
the thought that there is one person out
there who we're meant to find I blame
Hollywood and Disney the second is the
idea of growth this is based on Carol
Dweck's work on mindset Carol says that
people who have a growth mindset tend to
embrace failure they view it as an
opportunity to learn people with a fixed
mindset instead view failure is it ding
against their intelligence and they stop
trying
it turns out that it's remarkably
similar in relationships people who are
high on the growth spectrum tend to view
conflict as inevitable as something that
needs to be worked through and even as
an opportunity to become closer to your
partner people who are low on the
spectrum give up very easily destiny is
much more complicated early on it can
completely kill a relationship after all
you wouldn't be having a petty squabble
with your loved one about where to go
for dinner on Friday night if you were
meant to be with them right later on
it's much more complicated on the one
hand it can make you work harder to
salvage this relationship that you're
meant to be in but it can also cause
denial and avoidance of problems what's
really powerful to me about all of this
is it is completely in our minds we can
control it if we choose to put aside
this concept of destiny and instead
embrace the idea of growth in the idea
of working through the lows we can all
have happier and healthier relationships
when I thought of couples who did this
well I immediately thought of my
husband's grandparents grandma Aiden
pops have been married for 67 years two
years ago we celebrated their 65th
anniversary it was so moving to see how
happy they were to have their kids their
grandkids and their great grandkids all
assembled in one room this is a photo of
them in 1949 and they got married and
this is another photo more recently
taken right before the party when I call
to ask them what they thought about love
and relationships I learned some
interesting things first I learned that
my husband had sneakily been talking to
pops almost since the day we got married
and getting his advice I would argue
that jason has been employing Pops's
advice to great effect in our
relationship according to pops there are
three little words that can make for a
successful marriage and they are yes my
dear
but in all seriousness grama ADA did
give me some real material to work with
she said we've shared some incredible
highs the birth of our children as one
example but we've also shared some
really deep lows in particular the
health problems they've experienced
recently as they've gotten older at any
moment she said you have the choice to
stay in a relationship or to leave it
particularly when times get tough maybe
I'm a little bit higher on destiny than
I'd like to admit but I was surprised I
thought that they were going to talk
about love and the meant to be and
instead both of them just talked about
how hard it was this wasn't at all what
I was expecting to hear love is a wave
with highs and lows my wish for all of
us sitting in this room today is that we
can put aside this idea of destiny that
we can stop thinking about the meant to
be and instead embrace what we have
today if we embrace the work that the
lows take to get through we can all have
healthier and happier friendships family
relationships and yes even romantic
relationships with our loved ones thank
you